amanda gorban a young black author
recited her poem
the hills we climb at biden's
inauguration in it she called for peace
and unity and the togetherness of the
american people
and her poem inspired many including
dutch author marik lucas reinvelt
who is the youngest winner of the
international booker prize award
and she was chosen to translate gorman's
work
into dutch at the time of increasing
polarization
amanda gorman shows in her young voice
the power of spoken word
the power of reconciliation the power of
someone who looks into the future
instead of looking down when i was asked
to translate
all i could do was say yes and get
behind her
but it seems reinvelt underestimated the
increasing polarization
of today's perpetually offended society
the announcement
quickly caused an uproar why because
gorman is black and reinvent who's
translating her
is white and as we know in 2021
that is just simply unacceptable
naturally the mounting criticisms
led reinvelt to reject the assignment
completely
i am shocked by their prayer around my
involvement in the dissemination of
amanda gorman's message
and i understand people who feel hurt by
the choice
so yet again the fragile hurt
always offended activists got what they
wanted
and turned a message about unity and
peace
into yet another racial and identity
politics scandal and apparently from now
on
everything should just be segregated
based on superficial features like race
gender skin color etc and if you're
white
and not waving the flag of surrender
which is also white
then you just might be a racist
you